hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Game of Thrones Season 8
news to talk about we found out how long
all the episodes are gonna be and there
was an old interview that sophie Turner
did last year which confirms some of the
theories that we have about the Game of
Thrones Season 8 teaser trailer that
I'll play so we'll talk about the
episodes first then we'll talk about the
teaser trailer we're still doing the
Game of Thrones book giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
first big thing the reason why we found
out the Game of Thrones episode links is
because it was an international industry
trade conference going on there was a
foreign language news site that was
there that was just taking down all the
things that people were saying the
people that were there to present about
Game of Thrones we're talking about how
extra large the episodes were they
called them XXL then because it was in a
foreign language someone was translating
it to English and they specified exactly
how long all the episodes are going to
be so it should be noted that they're
still editing all the episodes like
they're not absolutely completed I mean
they finished shooting them but they're
finishing the special effects so these
runtimes could get a little bit longer
or a little bit shorter by a couple
minutes but just treat them like
approximations they're very close to
what the actual episode links will be
episodes 1 & 2 are both supposed to be
60 minutes long and then episodes 3 4 5
& 6 the finale are all supposed to be 80
minutes long so when all the HBO people
and the game of thrones producers have
been talking about them being feature
length that's what they mean feature
length is defined as anything longer
than 60 minutes typical Game of Thrones
episodes on average are closer to like
53 minutes based on previous seasons so
we'll compare these to the season 7 run
times because that's the closest
comparison they went way longer than
previous seasons had gone before
so episode 1 Dragonstone was 59 minutes
episode 2 Stormborn also 59 minutes
episode 3 the Queen's justice was 63
minutes episode 4 the spoils of war also
what they were calling the loot train
battle but what we should really call
the field of fire was only 50 minutes so
by season 7 standards that was a pretty
short episode even though it had one of
the best battles from the season episode
5 Eastwatch was 59 minutes episode
six beyond the wall the other really big
battle from the season was 70 minutes in
Episode seven the finale was 80 minutes
so even though there weren't any really
huge battles technically during the
finale they still had a big standoff in
the dragon pit that went on for a good
long time then they had to wrap up every
single person's storyline and they were
still kind of all in different places
because John and Daenerys had not yet
come back to Winterfell
so imagine most of the Game of Thrones
Season 8 episodes feel like the season 7
finale it's just that you have so many
characters all in the same place that
you just spend a lot of time with them
talking to each other in different
scenes so for the most part that's the
contributing factor in these longer
episodes you just have more episodes
with more moments like you saw in the
finale the exception to that though are
the two what seems like really big
battles that they're going to have
because Miguel's upon ik is directing
episodes 3 in episode 5 he's typically
known for directing their biggest type
of episodes he directed hardhome during
season 5 he directed battle the pastures
during season 6 and winds of winter
which was the season 6 finale so pretty
safe bet the Game of Thrones season 8
episode 3 in episode 5 which are both 80
minutes are gonna be giant battles at
least episode 3 because they've been
talking about how one of the battles at
least is gonna be the biggest thing that
they've ever done like an entire episode
with a huge battle so think about those
run times season 8 episode 3 eighty
minutes a giant battle with the night
king at Winterfell against Jon and
Daenerys as combined forces I've already
done a couple videos about what the
actors and the producers have said about
the differences in the way they filmed
their battle episodes but a really good
example would probably be hardhome on
steroids imagine like the super-sized
version of that with all of the main
characters with the exception of course
of Cersei in the golden company which
will be chilling out down at King's
Landing just hoping that they cancel
each other out up in the north even
though everyone's bummed out about the
fact that there's only six episodes the
actual total runtime in minutes when you
add all the minutes from the episodes up
is the exact same from Season 7 just
based on this preliminary report now
like I said I think that some of the
episodes as they're reporting here will
run a little bit longer and some will
run a little bit shorter but it'll still
probably average out to about the same
amount of runtime so seasons
was 440 total minutes through seven
episodes season eight is still supposed
to be about four hundred and forty
minutes total so it's the same amount of
content the season eight episodes are
also about 20 minutes longer on average
than the average length of the earlier
seasons when we used to get ten episodes
but each of the episodes was way shorter
most of the reactions that I've seen
from all you guys on social media so far
just within expectations like okay we
knew it was gonna be longer now we have
a clearer idea for what that's actually
gonna look like the funny thing about
all these super-sized episodes is that
back before we knew how long they were
gonna be I was actually kind of worried
that they would be longer than two hours
for a little while and just thinking
about how I would try to fit all that
information into a single YouTube video
for each episode if you're brand new to
the channel or you haven't seen the
videos that I've done four episodes in
previous seasons when episodes get way
longer typically what I'll do is is
there something that I don't have time
to talk about in my main episode video
I'll just do a separate video about it
later in the week so there's no worries
it's the final season of the main show
and we have all the Game of Thrones
prequel TV series stuff that'll be
happening at the same time so I'll do as
many bonus videos as we need to do to
cover everything just based on what you
guys want to talk about most I'll start
talking more about that when we get
closer to episodes actually dropping in
April but no worries we're gonna have
several trailers and promos before that
drops so there'll be plenty of other
stuff to freak out about before that
happens
there hasn't been any special word about
a potential Super Bowl trailer or any
new footage dropping because I don't
think the game of Thrones is gonna spend
millions and millions of dollars to drop
a 30-second clip during the Super Bowl
if they do decide to drop footage it'll
probably be separately on their social
media accounts so whatever ends up
happening I will totally make a video
for it no worries
but because everybody's been freaking
out about the Winterfell Game of Thrones
Season eight teaser trailer and all the
imagery and visual metaphors that they
were giving up so V Turner actually did
an interview last year that people dug
up where she confirmed some of the
things that I said during my trailer
breakdown a couple days ago so I'll play
that clip here it's audio only and this
is her at New York Comic Con at 2018
[Music]
I can say that say I say this every
season she recalls a Terran deceased
anointed the pasta season series she's
kind of been somewhat lost of questions
to be who she wants to be wants to
surround us up with and this season
she's very very Star Wars she knows she
knows what she asked for
she knows who she wants to be around and
she faces
[Music]
so if you had trouble hearing the audio
of sophie turner she just confirms that
the winterfell Crips season 8 teaser
trailer is meant to be more visual
metaphors and not actually be footage
from season 8 and not imply that Jon
Snow was gonna live to a great oiled age
mostly them trying to drum up interest
so don't look too much into what they're
saying here with these statues and why
they look a little bit different in
terms of ages she confirms that they
shot fake scenes she doesn't say how
many fake scenes but she did say they
would spend parts of days when they were
in Croatia just doing absolutely nothing
dressed up in costume it'll be fun to
find out what those were after the fact
when the season is already aired she
talks a little bit about the final scene
that she filmed which isn't necessarily
going to be at the end of the actual
finale she just says that they were
filming a scene for five days and that
happened to be the last scene but they
film out of order so the actual scene
could happen anywhere in the final
episode but I do expect that it is from
one of the final episodes when she says
the gift that they gave her is the
storyboards from their favorite Sansa
scene she doesn't say what that scene is
so I'm hoping that it's a scene from
season 8 at some point she also confirms
a little bit about Sansa art during
season 8 how she's a little more
self-assured she knows her place a
little bit more and other people respect
her especially the lords in the north
we'll talk more about death predictions
when we get actual season 8 footage so
no worries but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
extra long episodes run times there a
couple more promo videos that I'll post
over the next couple of weeks so no
worries but congratulations spotted
sharks do the giveaway winner from my
last big game of Thrones vid
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here to re-watch my Game of Thrones
Season 8 teaser trailer video with all
the Easter eggs and click here for all
my Game of Thrones season 8 promo videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you